merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues vous ne serez sans doute
pas surpris si je vous dis qu'après
trois discours nous ne sommes toujours
pas convaincus que la politique que vous
nous proposez va résoudre les problèmes
qui touchent nos compatriotes insécurité
immigration subie et chômage de masse
pour ne prendre que les trois plus
importants et qu'elle risque également
d'aggraver la dissolution progressive de
notre pays et de notre civilisation dans
un magma mondialisée après un discours
présidentiel totalement déconnectés de
la réalité vécue par l'immense majorité
des français nous avons celui d'un
gestionnaire comme si l'action politique
se limitait une simple vision comptable
il faut dire que dans ce domaine la
situation n'est pas brillante après les
deux derniers quinquennat la dette de
notre pays ayant bondi de 600 milliards
sous monsieur sarkozy alors soutenu par
votre famille politique d'origine
monsieur le premier ministre est de 340
milliards ce monsieur hollande dont
l'actuel président de la république
était alors le conseiller puis le
ministre après une décennie d'austérité
imposé par l'union européenne vous nous
proposez donc la même chose il faut dire
que neuer n'ayant pas récupéré une once
de souveraineté vos levier d'action sont
bien limiter ainsi votre objectif n'est
pas de faire baisser le chômage qui
touche plusieurs millions de nos
compatriotes mais d'abord de respecter
la règle maastricht yens des 3% pour
obéir aux commissaires bruxellois les
caisses sont vides qu'à cela ne tienne
vous augmentez les impôts
cg cigarettes diesel au vous patinez
certaines de certaines de ces hausses de
bons sentiments mais en réalité le but
est juste de faire rentrer de l'argent
sans avoir à changer de modèle et ce
sont encore les classes moyennes qui
vont subir de plein fouet cette
austérité
quant aux différentes promesses pour le
pouvoir d'achat aux baisses de charges
pour les entreprises notamment les tpe à
la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires on verra plus tard
la vérité est que vous devez attendre
que la commission européenne donne son
feu vert
en revanche certains lobbys eux se
frottent les mains l'industrie
pharmaceutique par exemple suite à votre
annonce d'augmenter considérablement le
nombre de vaccins obligatoires
au fait vous êtes vous demandé pourquoi
les maladies disparu de notre sol depuis
longtemps refusé surface il faut avoir
le courage de dire que l'immigration
massive dans ce domaine
et la meilleure piste de réponse même au
niveau européen vous somme était les
français à ces lobbys si j'en crois la
position récente de la france sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens première
couleuvre
pour le ministre d'état hulot d'ailleurs
permettez moi de relever que l'écologie
était bien vite balayés dans votre
discours
il faut dire que le combat écologique
qui doit être intégral c'est-à-dire
environnementale économique et sociale
se marie mal avec le modèle de
développement que vous vous évertuez à
défendre pourtant des mesures simples
pourraient être prises la mise en place
du patriotisme économique pour les
produits agricoles le refus des traités
de libre échange ou encore la création
d'une véritable filière d'énergies
renouvelables grâce à la priorité donnée
aux entreprises nationales du secteur
autre sujet grande absente votre
discours c'est extrêmement inquiétant la
sécurité et l'immigration
à part le fait de faire entrer un état
d'exception de l'état d'urgence dans le
droit commun rien alors que pour
renforcer la sécurité de nos
compatriotes il y a tant de mesures à
mettre en oeuvre notre droit vous
donnant déjà pas mal de possibilités par
exemple d'appliquer l'article 411 4 du
code pénal ou de mesures à prendre
contre le systématiques aux frontières
fermeture de la centaine de mosquées
radical expulsion des étrangers et
fiesch vs sur l'immigration et
l'enchaînement n'est pas n'est
évidemment pas fortuit n'en déplaise aux
ténors du politiquement correct rien non
plus enfin comme tant d'autres avant
vous vous promettez une réforme du droit
d'asile
j'étais alors enfant que votre mentor
monsieur juppé disait déjà la même chose
alors c'est beau de parler d'accueil des
migrants mais concrètement on fait quoi
je crois que pour leur dignité il
faudrait arrêter de leur mentir et
prendre comme l'australie des mesures
drastiques pour décourager ces personnes
de risquer leur vie pour un avenir guère
reluisant et lutter beaucoup plus
efficacement contre les passeurs surtout
quand ceux-ci sont déguisés en ong
pas un mot non plus sur le
communautarisme qui gangrène nos
quartiers qui fait que certains de nos
compatriotes ne se sentent plus chez eux
une culture voire une loi étrangère
ayant remplacé en quelque sorte la
civilisation française
concrètement que faites vous pour que
dans les rues de notre capitale les
femmes puissent se promener sans avoir à
je cite tenir son sac et baisser les
yeux avant de conclure un mot sur une
annonce discrète mais symbolique
nous avons bien senti ici dans cette
chambre représentant les collectivités
que vous comptiez vous attaquer aux
communes
symbole de notre pays on les diluants
davantage dans les inter communautés
dans les intercommunalités en leur
transférant d'ailleurs de nouvelles
compétences et en enlevant encore au
maire certaines prérogatives les
français sont attachés à leur commune et
à l'image du maire serviteurs publics de
proximité
soyez sûr que toute tentative de vous
attaquer à ces symboles sera fermement
combattu alors et je conclus
vous marchez mais vous ne savez pas vers
où la marche vous suffit mais le flou de
votre discours dans la lignée du flou de
la campagne risque de ne pas résister
longtemps au monde réel
soyez sûr que nous serons là pour vous
rappeler la réalité et pour combattre
toute mesure qui n'aura pas pour
objectif de protéger nos concitoyens de
défendre les plus fragiles d'entre eux
et de réarmer et comme économiquement et
moralement la nation française